Military. Take on you.
And. I know.
Where it's raining.
Well i think i can consider myself an
old timer. You want to say my name.
I'm not nicholson
and i think i can consider myself an old
timer now in this area which is a chain
and in an area although i
think you have to be here
but 60 years before you
consider the true blue oldtimer
but having been here for almost 20 years.
I consider myself a veteran
of a number of battles.
I've been living on the one property for
most of those almost 20 years trying to
make a go out of living on the land running
a nursery having some kids maintaining
a relationship which is a fulltime job
in itself fighting for the local forests
and staying involved in a lot of other
issues and doing university study
and a lot of other study as well and
trying to maintain my intelligence.
Despite a few problems with
work overload and so on. What.
I think you have to admit for a start
it's the ascetics you can't help being
affected by the place
when you walk into it.
But it's not just
that i think it's the sense of the
fragility in the face of human onslaughts
and in itself.
It's not fragile because it's been
around for roughly 100 million years.
So we know it's extremely durable.
That's withstood a number of
very dramatic climate changes
but in the face of what we've had about
to it. It's become extremely fragile.
And so i think was a combination of
these two the beauty and the fragility.
And also the fact that there was
so little left. We could see.
Quite obviously when we
came to the north coast
that the resident vegetation was on the
back foot and retreating very rapidly.
It still is by the way despite
and political decisions
that make people think it's saved in
fact it's still very much endangered.
And so
when we came to this area to buy land we
particularly want to get a bit of intact
forest.
So we ended up buying a piece of land
immediately adjacent to a state forest which
on the surface appeared to
look in pretty good shape
but as we became more adept at.
Interpreting the signs in
the rainforest we could see
that there had been some previous damage
from logging although a fair bit of it was
in quite good shape and so
we bonded very quickly to
that piece of land not only
the land that we farmed
but the land adjacent because it was very
beautiful at the end of the valley with
cliffs and tall forest and
beautiful cloud effects.
So we became very attached to this area
and felt we should. Fight in its defence.
When we discovered that it was in fact.
In danger in the immediate future and
that was after a few months after we
arrived at the place in 74 we discovered
that there were plans to log
the forest and logging at
that stage meant clear feeling and burning
and replacing with eucalypt forest.
Which 20 years later now has been discovered
to be not a very effective system
because either various timber problems
but you could see at the time
that it was wasn't a good thing to do
to clear fell a very complex ecosystem
and replace it with a monoculture
but the prevailing forestry ethic
at the time was to do this.
So i made it reaction was terror and.
And need to fight actually are
initial reaction was to run.
I have to admit sell the land go.
But by coincidence a number of people had
moved into this area at the same time
and just by discussing with
other people within days.
Our courage had come back and.
We've felt yes we would fight this
and it sprang very quickly the spirit of
fighting this issue came together very
quickly with quite a small bunch
of people that gave me hope.
The fact that so many people could feel
encouraged and feel they might even win
but i think at the time we had no idea
what sort of battle we were talking about
what sort of money. What sort of.
Toll in terms of relationships money general
lives was a really big thing to take
on which.
Maybe i wouldn't have done if i'd
known how bad it would be much.
Yes yes i worried about that
title for a long time of the.
The defense of my own
backyard is something
that i've worried about for some time because
this is the main accusation thrown at
greens. But now i realise
that it's very defensible it's it's quite
okay to fight for your own backyard.
In fact everyone should fight for their
own backyard and maybe if we all did
that
and didn't worry about the global issues
so much we could have a consciousness of
global issues but if we really concentrated
our energies on our local issue.
Something could be done.
And so now i feel much more confident
that we can really fight for a very small
issue it might even be one tree on the
street or it might be in this
case before thousand hectares.
But all these issues can be
fought with an enormous vehemence
and spirit by the people that are most
intimately involved and they're the ones
that go on for years you get the residents
that have lived at a place for 50 years
and they're still fighting
for the same piece.
I feel the same about this piece of forest
that i fought for it then another
it's under national park control.
I still worry about it in a
very intimate relationship.
And i still have arguments with national
parks about the way they manage the place.
Because although we've changed bureaucracies
the still the same problem that.
The same concept at the
park is there for human use
and we haven't yet switched to this.
Major radical. Mind movement that.
These places have got a right to exist
for their own sakes they've been there a
long time without us.
We're very late comer.
And we don't have to think that we're
the most important thing on the planet.
So i still fight for that and.
Motivation. Yes it's certainly a
deeper philosophical association.
The idea that these places have
a right to exist on their own
and i think along with being embarrassed
about fighting for my own backyard.
I was embarrassed to admit
that it might be a passionate
or religious feeling for the land.
But now again i'm much
more confident about that.
And the accusation
that the green movement is somehow religious
has been thrown about very flippantly.
But i think we can claim
that and not show to throw
that away because what else have we got
going for us with the demise of so many
other religions.
Something has to fill the place because
humans do have a need for spirituality
and what can be more spiritual
than the whole planet.
So i feel we have to grasp
that one and and fight for it.
Something maybe like chris eight of
which is a bit of a common image
but i feel quite strongly that we
have to think of ourselves as that.
Can you.
On this.
Further on the spiritual side of things i
don't like to espouse obvious dogmas like
that the gaia hypothesis even though
i feel that's completely plausible.
I think it's much more
of a personal issue.
But i just happen to have the same personal
philosophy along with a lot of other
people. And i guess you can call it.
Deep ecology that there
is a name for it now
or there's the dark green
environmental ism a number of names
and a lot of them are derogatory.
But i feel happy to espouse those
and take them on on that on a very
deep. Level because i feel it.
We're just beginning to learn
the depth of spirituality and.
Emotional feeling that the
aborigines had for the land.
And i only i've only lived here 20 years.
I don't depend on it financially
it's not my god it's not my food.
It's not any of those things but
it's still terribly important to me.
So i've got only got a glimmering
of what it meant to those people.
And i feel the more that people can
have some sort of feeling for the land.
The more hope we have got of rescuing
the planet because it's this divorce of
feeling. That has got us into big trouble.
Now and it's we've now got the
land in the relationship that.
That slaves and masters have been in
where the master has all the rights
and responsibilities
and in fact you can only really
own the slave by destroying it.
And that's what we've found in
australian relationships with land
that unless you're doing something to it.
Clearing it or plowing it
you don't really own it.
So we have to turn our attitudes
to the land on on their heads
and include the land in our morality which
is very difficult for most australians
to feel because they've always
had the frontier attitude
that it's a battle to
conquer it. You know. Yes.
It's very sad that that alienation
exists because in the end it will be.
Found doom ridden doesn't it.
But it will be the death of us if we can't
start including the land in the way we
feel in the way we love
what hope of we've got
and this increasingly becomes a problem
with the dominance of of economics as the
main mode of thinking
that everything absolutely everything
can be translated into dollar terms
and i saw a couple of days ago
ross kelly talking about.
That the control of pollution and the.
The reversal of the degradation in
rivers has to be tied into economics
and i just groaned thinking that.
People need to do it for the river sake
and for the land's sake not
because it's going to pay them
or not pay them to do the
right or wrong thing. Yes.
No.
That's right.
Yes it's very disturbing
especially when you realize
that a lot of the activities that are
actually degrading contribute to the g
and p or the economy as a whole.
These two things are non-compatible so
we maybe have to start thinking about
abandoning our economic system which is
very difficult because the belief in
perpetual growth is so profound that
you virtually can't even bring it up.
It's like saying mother's milk
poisonous or something like that
that just doesn't follow.
But we need something as radical as that
and that's why i think the people that.
Started working in nimbin 20 years ago.
Can still contribute a lot because they
have that basically very radical idea that.
The system has to go. Even
though you and i are.
I can say are entrenched in the system
to some extent we've published books
and we've printed them on paper that
came from trees that were filled
and we live in a wooden house
and we use the postal system
and all these other things i still feel
if i can let that go if i need to.
We just can use that as a
vehicle to change minds
but we don't have to be attached to it.
We have to be attached to consumerism as
not only a way of life but as an ethic
and as a duty to keep the economy
going. It's an absurd proposition.
We have to learn how to let go
and i think that's what niman has with
all its problems and all its horrors.
Has really taught a lot of people that you
can let go and live a lot more simply.
And i know the thing i feel very
strongly about this possibly not.
Not a sequitur from what we've been
talking about but i feel strongly
that with all the problems
in nimbin in this area.
We didn't have to prove
that we could actually solve the
whole planet's problems in one go.
It seems unfair to me to
focus on the alcoholics
and the drug addicts in the streets.
Look at mainstream society you can't say
it's squeaky clean it has no problems.
So it's ok to have problems we just
have to be proud of the things that
that have occurred and a lot of that is
the putting a crack into the main system.
The assumption that consumerism
is the only way to go.
I think there's a lot to be proud
of in the last 20 years since.
Nimbin and rainier creek
and all the other issues
but there's an awful
long way to go as well.
You know.
I think. From 1974 which is
when you and i first discovered
that the force was to be locked.
There was a campaign until 1979 of just the
conventional methods of fighting issues
that was endless letters to ministers
endless submissions appeal for clemency
invitations to visit the area
and so on all of which chinked away
at the edifice of forestry expertise
but we didn't actually get to
a point where we could win.
Even though they'd compromise
to a certain extent.
But we felt in view of what was
happening to the forest in this area.
This wasn't really a compromise.
So we kept fighting and it wasn't
until almost the last minute
when the blockade started
to occur in september 1979
that the group the main group called to
rainier native forest action group actually
contemplated a blockade. We do
ways felt we must win before then.
Because the argument
seemed to be so apparent.
How could they not listen to what we're
saying the naivete staggers me now we just
thought
that they would have to accede to our
demands because they were so obvious
and so we didn't actually have
a blockade planned at all.
We joked about it in very lighthearted
terms that no one had organised anything.
And so when the crunch came and the
bulldozers were definitely coming.
We put out a call at the
local market which was.
Called the china market just a local
market of kraft people put it.
Call did a couple of minor bits vegetating
and bangor we had. Oh i don't know what.
How many people there
were at the first day
but about 100 came almost immediately
which really floored it because we had no
idea that they should taken such
a hold on people's imagination.
Unfortunately for the people
and the only nato force action group who
had been working on the political side
but neglected the social side the
people who came were very good at
that stuff a lot of them
came from communities
and began to work out a social
system extremely effectively
and also a physical system for for life
support for cooking washing water.
Childminding health everything else.
Just staggered me how quickly
they could get that together.
And so we all tended to feed off each
other we need to be able to support each
other because there were a lot of problems
that always in a bunch of people like
that there are a lot of personal problems
and conflicts
and difficulties in solving them especially
if you work on the consensus system
and don't have a hierarchy.
So there were problems
but it was an extremely exciting
time when we all felt very strongly
that we were doing
something very important
and historic.
The blockade went on for. I think two or
three weeks it's hard to remember now.
So long ago. I feel i should have these
figures in my memory but it was about
that long. And not from from the very
beginning there were some police involved
but these numbers escalated very quickly
when rand attempted to tough it out.
And we got up to. Dozens of police at some
stage and how many 20 20. Paddy wagons.
We had to have some photographs which
were quite graphic of the number of blue
shirts that there were there
and as always with all these demonstrations
you had some extremely heavy police
that were very intimidating
and i mean on the other scale
some who are very supportive
and just said i'm doing my job
but i agree with you sow.
There was quite a concerted campaign to
tackle the police themselves on a personal
level not on aggressive level. And i in
particular had an experience when i.
For once was up in the forest on my own
just getting a bit of an up because i was
so exhausted and came across one of
the upper echelon cops who was lost.
And i thought i had my
chance to lose this bastard
and make it really
embarrassing for him but
that i thought no i
have to to do good p.r.
So i in fact chatted with him
and took them even i split
and led him out of the forest
and i think he was grateful
but he realised he was very vulnerable.
He didn't know the bush
come from somewhere else
and he felt afraid of the place was i
felt as if i was in my living room.
I felt so at home in
that piece of forest.
You know just talking to them
treating them like people
and listening which i've learnt subsequently
is absolutely vital not to even try
and put your ideas across just ask
questions and ask how it is for them.
And sometimes you get an
enormous rush of feeling from
that person because they may never
have been listened to before.
And i particularly knows this
that nobody which was later demonstration
for another piece of forest nearby.
When a group of demonstrators
and i entered the prohibited area of forest
where there were some loggers guarding
some equipment. Not that we
were threatening it anyway
and some people attacked them verbally not
abusing but yelling arguments at them
and you could see the
reaction was a brick wall.
But i perceive
that if i just listen to one of the chaps
in particular the one with the doberman
and the one who is really likely to let
fly with a fist first talking to him he
would come down and it was true.
It was worked like magic.
Just listening to his grievances.
And finding out what was going on for them
was very important because they have got
extremely important grievances
that no one was listening to
and i still feel strongly that the.
People at the bottom of the
ranks in forestry and.
In the the logging camp are the ones
that get victimized all along the line.
They're the ones that get thrown out
when you get meal rationalizations one
meal taking over another the blokes get
dumped. It's the bottom
blokes that get dumped.
Every time
when you get a big new machine it's
the less skilled ones are get dumped.
Every time
and now they felt they were being victimised
by the greens as well so they were
just in an absolutely no win situation.
So i think we're few started
listening to someone
and listen to what they were worried
about they had plenty to say
and we needed to hear that stuff we couldn't
just forced our own ideas onto them.
Because comparatively the greenside
was more. Had more internal support.
We had formulated ideas
to a certain extent
and had it quite a good network of
people who knew who felt the same way
but these logging blokes felt isolated
you could see a very isolated
and very threatened and of course you
threatened if you love a good looks like.
Getting shot from under you
and they're not only threatened for most
are threatened by the mill ownership as
well as we've seen subsequently there's
huge employment losses with these mills
either closing down and
taking other mills over
or putting in new machines to dice these
books so they were very threatened
and i think we could have done
more on that score more listening
and more actually physically
helping these people.
But it's going to get people.
I think the throne you creek
and they might not be issues
were very formative in bringing.
Many of the greens together
and a lot of green thought
but i don't think we can take the credit
for a lot of the green movement in the
area. I think that was something that
was coming. Anyway. Was quite clear.
But at the time the
green movement did feel
that the support from sydney wasn't forthcoming
and there's a certainly the urban.
Tide that is there. Certain tired
green movement that compared with us.
Was very straight
and we certainly looked like the dirty
hippie people in the hills which wasn't true
but it was just the image that came
across at the time and so we needed
that the city suited people to to
help us help the media realize
that in fact this was a very widespread
movement. Unfortunately when.
Of course the people up here were talking
to the media always the cameras go to the
most way out looking crazies.
But the bulk of the movement
wasn't there wasn't these people.
It was very straight live more people
and people in this area in the valley some
selves who may not have dressed in suits
and ties but had a very well thought
out philosophy and. A lot of.
A lot of thinking going into the
way that they were operating
and also a lot of professional and
other expertise plenty of people with.
I think advertising in advertising
training or photographic training
or teaching training or.
Media training all sorts of different skills
that we could apply to this situation.
Area. Reputation breeding. Extreme.
Yes that's something to be
proud of. I think we need.
This area has had a reputation for
breeding green extremists which i think is
something we can be extremely proud of.
In fact there's now a t-shirt
that you can buy put up by the local
environment centre same green extremist.
So that's a good thing
but i'm a bit worried
that the green extremist idea may
get hijacked by commercialism
and be sold as a nice idea
but we really don't have to do
anything very constructive about this
and i think that's something
that the whole movement in this area
has to really worry about that.
Our opposition.
The world of economics and
commercialism and large bureaucracies
that are intent on doing the same as they've
always done these people have now got
the skills. Who use green
ideas against us and so
that the normal person in the street thinks
they're doing something useful by using
unbleached toilet paper
and feel good about it
but are basically still a
major part of the problem.
So i think that's the next challenge for
us we appear to have had a major win
that looks like people really
care about this these issues.
But underneath it all has
been a very minor change
and that's what we have to work on now.
You know a changed.
Story.
You know.
There's certainly been a very strong
anti green movement come into being.
Since the especially
that quick battle where for a start we
were ahead because we had all innovative
ideas such as using advertising which
hadn't been thought of a green issue before
so we are ahead on that score. But now
there's a problem with the backlash to
that
and an increasing sophistication of tactics
from large bureaucracy such as advertising
and getting across what i
considered to be false information.
But i'm not too concerned about the backlash
against green movements in the general
population. I think that
is actually diminishing
and green ideas are increasing because of
the evidence is so apparent we don't have
to pretend that it's not happening. So i
think the violent anti-green movements.
Will go in time
but what we have to deal with in the
immediate future is is the apathy
and the belief
that it's all okay so i think you get
people like the more extreme members of the
forestry protection for. Society
association should know that.
Times such as rage was that.
Rational action against green.
Extremists.
That meant rational action i
think against green extremists
and i can see where these people.
Come from they come from a position
of fear and powerless knus
and it's easy to attribute causes
and agreement green green
to the most obvious cause.
So they will continue to be a problem
but they will diminish what we have to
guard against is increasing apathy.
So it's quite obvious with the greenhouse
effect having a big impact on public
consciousness for the first year
or two it was talked about and.
It's not discussed too openly. Changed.
Of options
and i don't know.
You know. Now.
Offering to provide. You.
Yes the green movement certainly has to
start offering some positive alternatives.
We have been saying no
for a very long time
and unfortunately getting the image
of course that we're very negative
and against everything. But
i think that's reasonable.
Not to have these solutions when you're
pointing to a problem. It's like.
A doctor saying you've got cancer
and they mightn't have the answers
but they still have to point
out that you've got a problem.
So i think it's reasonable
for us to do that.
But of course to increase public credibility
we do have to provide more in the way
of positive answers. Not
that we haven't been doing this for some
time talking about reforestation being
number one priority in this area with
the huge percentage of the great land
that we have this is obviously a big question
which could solve a lot of employment
problems of a degradation problem
solve a lot of planetary problems.
So we haven't been neglecting this issue
but we have to do it more effectively.
And i think. As far as i'm concerned
the economics is a major problem.
And so green people have to show more
explicitly how to live very softly on the
earth and this means scaling down our.
Economic involvement out
our desire to have things
and becoming done with these socially
mobile as some of the people on hbo.
Do you suggest that it's
a very good idea that.
We have to stop aspiring to own more things
which obviously have a terminal impact
on the planet. So we have to sabotage
the economic system from within
and this will have enormous ramifications
for the forestry industry apart from
anything else.
We're not saying don't use trees we're
saying use an awful lot less than we are at
the moment and that goes for
everything else as well.
So i think if greens can show themselves
to be capable of living lightly on the
planet. And coming up with
some alternative suggestions.
They're going to look a lot more be looked
on a lot more favorably by the general
populace at the moment we have
a few people that consider
that having a rosewood table is
like if you plan to rosewood.
But as far as i'm concerned. One seedling
doesn't equal 1000 year old tree.
We have to do a lot more than that we
have to start using pine for instance.
Which here and i have done in this house.
Because those plans are in the
ground now we should use them
and not keep using the old for
that no matter how great it sound to plant
a tree is just really not going to work.
We have to back off for some
period now and that these forests
and indeed the whole country recover from
our ravages it's a difficult one because
you can see the economic
impact will be enormous.
That's why we have to escape
from this strait jacket.
Of economic consciousness that
we have at the moment that
that money is what will count money will
get us out of our problems increased
growth increased use of resources
will get us out of these problems
and a child can see that
this is a nonsense.
Good questions.
Yes.
Working out how to stay green and
be completely non-hypocritical
and completely pure is extremely difficult
and i've decided it's
completely impossible
and for a long time i've been
vulnerable to the accusation of.
Well you drive a car you wear
shoes you walk on wouldn't flaws
and i still worry about that
one and i still want to be.
As pure as possible while realizing
that if i was obsessed with consuming things
i'd be not only contributing to the g
and p but i'd be untroubled by
feelings of hypocrisy i would in
that sense be a good person.
Whereas now i feel that if i cut a treat
and i my property to make a fence post.
I'm somehow involved in
oh you know hypocrisy.
But i'm coming to terms with that
and i think all i can do is my best
and most people in fact
do that all the time
but we greens have to be
even more aware of that
and not let ourselves slip into
into bad ways but i'm aware
that you know nursery for instance we produce
hundreds of thousands of trees every
year which sounds like a great idea
but we use plastic pots we use
recycled ones where we can
but we still use some new ones. So
we're very open to accusations of.
Bad practices because i haven't
personally investigated the factory
that makes these plastic pots
and no doubt it's dumping its effluent
into the local creek. Who knows.
And we use sand that's
dredged from the river
and no doubt the sand there because
the the up slopes have been cleared
and so i'm still responsible for everything
that goes on and i'm really aware
that i personally have got a stake in
the whole degradation of the planet.
So although this can give you
an enormous load of guilt.
You have to somehow put it on the one
shoulder not have it on both shoulders.
So use your guild as a motivator motivating
force to keep you as clean as you
possibly can but don't be over when.
Good by and
that is the trick for almost all the greens
i now know operating the veterans of
these old campaigns of how
to manage their guilt burden
and their hypocrisy burden
and still be effective positive happy people
who know they've got an issue to work
on and don't want to be
crippled by the feelings
that maybe something wrong
with what they're doing.
For instance i use a car
and i'm very aware of that
that i would step a lot more lightly on
the planet if i walk and serve driving.
But the problems at the moment are
so crucial that you have to shortcut
and fact use the paraphernalia
of the opposition to fight it.
So that's why i use a
computer which no doubt.
Had 50's involved it's manufactured
the list of hypocrisy with endless.
I just try to get them
under control. Thank you.
Very at the very same time.
Looking back now after 20 years.
From an experiment on.
I've come to the
conclusion that the ethics
and ideas of the original even
people were and are still correct
but often they're swatted by just
the prevailing lack of energy and.
Hopelessness even a of a lot of people
unfortunately the people who are doing all
the destroying of the planet.
The ones i've got all the energy
and initiative are the ones i've got
precisely the wrong ideas about stimulating
the economy and consuming more and. And.